So what is GraphQL? As a front end developer, you
often need to send requests to multiple services in
order to fill your UI with data. For example,
you have issues of under fetching or need to
send requests to multiple services in order to
collect all the data you need. You might also
be under fetching where you get too much data from
a single request. So you need to filter those out
in your front end application. GraphQL solves this
problem by giving you one API that you can call to
collect all the data you need. GraphQL is a query
language for APIs, much like how SQL is a query
language for databases. For example, the following
SQL statement where you would select a number of
fields from a number of tables looks like this
in GraphQL. An operation, for example, query,
which is for reading data and to find all the
fields that you want to retrieve, all in a single
request. So the way GraphQL is able to do this
is by having a type system. The type system is
defined in a GraphQL schema. In a schema, you will
find all the available operations such as query
for reading data, mutations for adding, editing,
or deleting data or subscriptions to subscribe to
updates in your data. The response for all these
operations are defined in your types. These types
will have type definitions for all the fields that
are available in your schema. In order to get the
data from the GraphQL API you would need to take
your statement and pass it to the GraphQL API in a
document. This data is usually passed over HTTP
and returns data in JSON format. In the case
where we want to connect multiple data sources,
the GraphQL API will make sure to collect the data
from your underlying services. In this scenario
GraphQL could also serve as a middleware, which
we also call GraphQL Federation. In this video we
talked about GraphQL. I showed you how GraphQL can
help you solve problems you might be facing as
a front end developer such as over fetching or
under fetching. How to write the statements in
GraphQL and how GraphQL as the GraphQL schema
where all the time definitions are defined. And
finally, GraphQL can be used as a middleware to
collect data from all your data sources. Thank
you. If you like this video and want to see more
like it, please like and subscribe. If you have
questions, please drop them in the comments below.